stephanie heim ist unsere frau vor ort
nicht mehr alleine sondern sie hat sich
ein polizeisprecher dazu geholt um
nochmal genauer nachzufragen wie sich
die lage entwickelt hat und vielleicht
noch entwickeln wird stefanie
[Musik]
schwierigkeit liegt ganz einfach daran
dass die menschen sich hier unvernünftig
zeige nicht einsichtig zeigen
tatsächlich auch alles was wir anbieten
ob alles woran wir appelliert haben
nicht eingehen zuwiderhandeln und er ist
deshalb wohl schwer den wasserwerfer
einsetzen und für stück vorarbeiten oder
auch das müssen wir verhältnissen machen
wir können was er da völlig einfach so
einsetzen sondern auch da geht es darum
ist es jetzt hier darauf oder sich an
welcher stelle können wir eventuell
durch reine körperliche gewalt vorgehen
also die schieben und drängen ich gehe
darum die menschen hier von dem ort zu
entfernen
die sie ja an nichts gehalten haben wir
haben dazu aufgefordert im nasen schutz
zu tragen den kann man nicht daran
appelliert mindestabstände einzuhalten
all das wurde ignoriert als das rudel
nicht
das ist ein extrem verschiedene gruppe
von leuten für junge männer frauen
kinder kleine hunde und was das für sie
noch mal wechseln als schwierig
platz zu sagen weil ich ein erstes mal
tat erinnern wo das aber deutlich
schneller gehen
genau das ist die schwierigkeit die
zusammensetzung der vormaligen
versammlungsteilnehmer der menschen die
sich hier zusammengefunden haben denn
wir können natürlich nicht wie gegen
einfach gewaltbereite also eine masse
aus gewaltbereiten direkt vor den
sondern wir müssen hier ganz sauber
abgestimmt vorgehen und genau gucken wo
setzen wir den wasserwerfer wie ein
gerade wenn kinder sich in der nähe
befinden was es sehr schwer macht müssen
wir ganz ganz behutsam vorgehen warum
warten sie überhaupt nötig diesen platz
jetzt zu räumen weil man hätte auch
sagen können wir lassen die leute jetzt
hier stehen diese tür eine eine gruppe
kommt keiner mehr da zogen keiner mehr
weg aber lassen wir so genau dafür haben
wir sorge getragen dass auch keine
weiteren personen hin zu strömen das war
der eine aspekt wir mussten aber darauf
achten dass auch der mindestabstand
eingehalten wird das in der mode
nasenschutz getragen wird es geht ja
darum infektionsgefahren
infektionsrisiken zu minimieren eben
indem man sich an hygienevorschriften
handel hält aber den kann man sie nicht
nach wien hat man sich verweigert man
hat alle ansprachen die hier getätigt
haben ignoriert man hat sich dem zuwider
gesetzt und wir müssen eben dafür sorge
tragen dass alle anderen menschen
darüber hinaus auch nicht geführt werden
weil wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
infektion fraktions gefahren die hier
entstehen deutlich über die grenzen von
berlin hinaus menschen gefährden oder
sogar darüber liegen
wissen sie aus wie vielen verschiedenen
ecken die leute kamen
wir haben eine mobilisierung aus dem
gesamten bundesgebiet zu verzeichnen und
wo jetzt genau wer kommt das kann ich
ihnen natürlich nicht belastbar sagen
aber wir haben sowohl aus süd einfach
aus norddeutschland ein zustrom
verständigen
was glauben sie wie lange das noch
dauern wird hier der ganze einsatz
wir sind verantwortlich dafür wir nehmen
unsere verantwortung auch wahr dass die
risiken die inflationsrisiken verringert
werden indem wir die menschen
auseinander bringen und das wären über
harnisch weitermachen das heißt es kann
bis in die abendstunden dauern wir
werden aber nicht müde das zu tun denn
es geht darum dass wir diese
verantwortung auch wirklich wahrnehmen
dann gab er jetzt auf jeden fall sagen
wer sich bei dieser demo nicht mit krone
angesteckt hat der wird mit dank der
wasserwerker sicherlich ein schnupfen
davon tragen aber aus berlin was das
jetzt erstmal danke schön stephanie heim
nicht nur die teilnehmer der
demonstrationen bringen argumente vor
gegen das infektionsschutzgesetz über
das der bundestag zunächst berät dann
entscheiden soll am nachmittag auch noch
der bundesrat übrigens auch opposition
und juristen haben bedenken geäußert
bevor wir darüber sprechen welche
bedenken dass sind die berechtigt sie
sind oder nicht wollen wir erst mal
schauen was das neue gesetz denn
überhaupt regeln soll
was ist das infektionsschutzgesetz es
regelt dass grundrechte eingeschränkt
werden können zum beispiel die
versammlungsfreiheit oder die
bewegungsfreiheit um die bürger vor
besonders gefährlichen oder ansteckenden
krankheiten zu schützen
ziel der änderungen im bundestag eine
präzise rechtsgrundlage für corona
maßnahmen dazu soll ein neuer paragraf
im infektionsschutzgesetz her
§ 28a der legt schwellenwerte von
infektionen fest ab denen maßnahmen
möglich sind 35 sowie 50 neuansteckungen
pro 100000 einwohner innerhalb von
sieben tagen
laut gesetzentwurf müssen
rechtsverordnung mit denen einzelne
bundesländer dann corona maßnahmen
erlassen begründet werden und sind
zeitlich befristet im regelfall gelten
sie vier wochen
die bundesregierung muss den bundestag
demnach regelmäßig über den stand der
epidemie unterrichten und § 28a listet
auf welche schutzmaßnahmen konkret
angewendet werden können
etwa abstands gebote und masken pflicht
kontakt beschränkungen oder das
schließen von geschäften das also soll
das neue infektionsschutzgesetz regeln
die bundesregierung will ihre corona
politik damit auf eine stärkere
rechtliche basis stellen
es hatte ja zum schluss zahlreiche
gerichtsurteile gegeben die immer wieder
maßnahmen gekippt hatten sei es zum
beispiel das beherbergungs verbot oder
die konkrete ausgestaltung von
verordnungen wie allgemeine masken
verpflichtungen
gleichzeitig soll das parlament mehr
mitsprache bekommen dass debattiert also
zur stunde über den entwurf der
bundesregierung und darüber sprechen wir
mit thomas reich hat unserem
korrespondenten in der hauptstadt thomas
wie erlebst du die debatte im bundestag
auch so aufgeheizt wie auf der straße
oder geht man das im bundestag eher
sachlich an
nein das ist ziemlich aufgeheizt also
selbst für lebendige debatten für die
der bundestag ja durchaus bekannt ist
ist es heute eine sehr aufgeheizte
stimmung verantwortlich dafür ist vor
allem die fdp die im grunde versucht die
proteste der korona oder corona gegner
ins parlament zu tragen ein
fdp-abgeordneter ein notorischer corona
verharmloser hat heute offenbar auch
versucht ohne maske ins parlament zu
kommen erwarten war dass er davon daran
an der bundestagspolizei gehindert wurde
die afg hat dann versucht mit einem
geschäftsordnungsantrag die debatte
insgesamt zu verhindern und hat den
vergleich zum ermächtigungsgesetz von
1933 der nazis herangezogen was zu
großer empörung bei allen anderen
fraktionen geführt hat die umgekehrte
als die laut vorgeworfen haben dass sie
ihre eigentlichen parlamentarischen
rechte in der mich die mitarbeiter an
diesem gesetzentwurf in den ausschüssen
gar nicht wahrgenommen hat sondern eben
nur die große bühne des großen plänen
und bisher nutzen wollte also im grunde
eine art protest im parlament der den
protest vor der vor dem parlament
spiegeln sollte also saftige rhetorik im
bundestag höre mir doch mal rein in wort
und bild was da bislang debattiert wurde
gegen mittag beginnt die polizei damit
die demonstrationen im berliner
regierungsviertel mit wasserwerfern
aufzulösen
tausende gegner der korona
schutzmaßnahmen sind hier unterwegs um
gegen das neue infektionsschutzgesetz zu
protestieren
über das im bundestag gerade abgestimmt
wird die stimmung seit tagen aufgeheizt
durch die behauptung ein zitat
ermächtigungsgesetz passiere das
parlament eine behauptung die die afg in
der bundesratssitzung aufgreift und
damit die gesetzesnovelle in die nähe
zum beginn der nazi diktatur rückt die
heutige gesetzesvorlage ist eine
ermächtigung der regierung wie es das
zeitgeschichtliche zeiten nicht mehr gab
die tonlage ist damit auch im bundestag
gesetzt sie haben gemerkt dass ihre
radikalen freunde da draußen im social
media dazu aufrufen die wege ins
parlament zu blockieren und weil sie die
für sich einnehmen wollen wollen sie
genau so den weg der gesetzgebung
blockieren wie die da draußen den weg
ins parlament blockieren wollen
wenn leute wie sie mit solchen
geschichtlichen parallelen spielen
sie diskreditieren sich unsere
demokratie sondern sie warten sie
verächtlich
zur abstimmung steht die gesetzesnovelle
mit der die regierung für ihre maßnahmen
zur pandemie bekämpfung eine bessere
gesetzliche grundlage schaffen will
wir brauchen in dieser pandemie die
befugnisse und instrumente zu handeln
und zu entscheiden
zum schutz und symbole unserer
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schnell
durchgepeitscht mit zu weitreichenden
befugnissen für die exekutive keine
mitsprache für das parlament das ist die
kritik von fdp und linken die gegen die
novelle stimmen jeder eingriff in die
grund und freiheitsrechte die so bitter
erkämpft worden sind die so unser
fundament ist dass uns hier streiten
können bedarf der debatte und zustimmung
oder ablehnung des bundestages und genau
das ist nicht vorgesehen
deswegen kann
die grünen dagegen wollen der
gesetzesnovelle zustimmen um 15 uhr
kommt der bundesrat zu einer
sondersitzung zusammen danach soll der
bundespräsident das gesetz
unterschreiben die stimmung auf berlins
straßen bleibt unterdessen angespannt
viele demonstranten weigern sich den
anordnungen der polizei folge zu leisten
2000 beamte sind im einsatz soweit also
die bisherigen höhepunkte der
parlamentsdebatte damit noch mal zurück
zu unserem hauptstadt korrespondenten
thomas reichert bleiben wir mal beim
punkt mitspracherechts des parlaments
das soll ja gestärkt werden dieses recht
trotzdem spricht einfach an die fdp
immer noch von mangelnder
beteiligungsmöglichkeit des parlaments
und die querdenken bewegungen und die
demonstranten aber auch schon gehört
haben sprechen sogar von einer diktatur
wie passt das zusammen
also vielleicht muss man erst mal sagen
was soll dieses gesetz eigentlich
bewirken bislang ist es so dass die
verordnungen die so weitreichend in
unser leben seit dem frühjahr seit dem
märz eingreifen
auf der basis eines infektions gesetze
schutz gesetzes laufen mit verschiedenen
änderungen seitdem die im grunde hat
generalklausel sind die im grunde den
freifahrtschein geben für diese
verordnungen
das reicht der politik nicht mehr aus
sie hat reagiert damit auch auf kritik
von experten und aus der bevölkerung und
diese eingriffe diese verordnungen der
exekutive soll nun genauer geregelt
werden erstmal soll geklärt werden wann
sollen diese angriffe dort gelten es
müssen bestimmte voraussetzungen geld
nämlich die pandemie regel
zweitens soll es abgestuft sein je
nachdem wie groß die infektionen sind
und drittens soll geklärt werden welche
beschränkungen denn persönlichkeiten das
ist das eine auf der anderen seite gibt
es da natürlich kritik von seiten der
fdp aber auch von der linkspartei auch
von den von den grünen zur frage was ist
denn daran verhältnismäßig ist das
sinnvoll wieder vorgegangen wird und auf
der anderen seite gibt es dann eben die
fundamentale opposition der afd
die im grunde per se gegen korona
verordnungen eine aufgabe von
grundrechten sieht wobei sie dabei
natürlich auch vergisst dass auch ein
grundrecht auf leben und auf gesundheit
und auf körperliche unversehrtheit
besteht das ist der konflikt den wir
heute auch im parlament besichtigt haben
und dem grund auch diese debatte so so
lebhaft und zum teil auch aufgeheizt
gemacht hat wir haben in den vergangenen
tagen schon und heute auch wieder viele
falschinformationen gehört denen
vielleicht auch der eine oder andere
demonstrant aufgesessen ist oder sehr
viele der demonstranten um es mal auf
den punkt zu bringen
liegt das vielleicht auch daran dass die
große koalition erst sehr spät auf
kritik an der bisherigen praxis an der
bisherigen kroner politik reagiert hat
dann mit heißer nadel gestrickt hat und
in der eile vielleicht vergessen hat
oder versäumt hat zumindest gut zu
informieren und die menschen mitzunehmen
also ganz klar ist dass dieses gesetz
mit heißer nadel gestrickte wurde dass
es eine große eile ist und dass die
kommunikation insgesamt der korona
maßnahmen von seiten der bundesregierung
aber auch der länder gerade in den
letzten tagen nicht besonders glücklich
war dass bund länder treffen am montag
der ministerpräsidenten mit kanzlerin
merkel war sehr von streit geprägt und
von forderungen und unterschiedlichen
beschlussvorlagen wo die leute auf den
kopf geschüttelt haben zum beispiel die
regelung dass kinder und jugendliche in
zukunft nur noch einen freund oder eine
freundin treffen dürften kinder und
jugendliche die theben in klassen mit 30
mitschülern sitzen und einem nachmittag
nur ein treffen können das war heute
auch im parlament noch mal spielte das
noch mal eine rolle
auf der anderen seite ja es ist durchaus
nicht ungewöhnlich dass gesetze schnell
gestrickt werden
manchmal ist eben auch eile geboten die
frage ist hat wurden die spielregeln
eingehalten wurden die alv ausschüsse
hatten die eine chance sich dazu äußern
und das war tatsächlich der fall das
muss man einfach so sagen es wurde
behandelt und es wurde das auch
nachgebessert es gibt verschiedene
fassungen dieses gesetzes und die
regierungskoalition hat dann natürlich
auch auf einwände zum beispiel von
seiten der fdp oder auch der von bündnis
90/die grünen reagiert und noch mal
anpassungen gemacht das heißt es ist
jetzt hier keine schnell verordnung in
ayl durchgang sondern es ist ein
schneller parlamentarische prozess an
dem die fraktion im parlament durchaus
gelegenheit hatten sich damit
einzubringen
thomas reichert dankeschön für diese
hintergrund informationen und
einschätzungen
bis bald das gesetz hat nicht nur eine
politische dimension an sondern
natürlich auch eine rechtliche darum
geht es letztendlich es geht um die
grundrechte von uns allen und da haben
auch juristen bedenken geäußert darüber
wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit unseren
zdf rechtsexperten christian decker
christian bedenken von rechtsexperten
zum beispiel was die klarere definition
von maßnahmen von corona maßnahmen
angeht das sollte ja mit dem gesetz
geregelt werden
genauso auch die voraussetzungen für
diese maßnahmen was genau ist damit
gemeint ist warum ist das immer noch zu
schwach
laut juristen also bisher ist es so dass
im infektionsschutzgesetz eine
allgemeine klausel drin steht und gar
keine konkreten maßnahmen also neben den
vergangenen acht monaten wurden die
ganzen kroner maßnahmen die die länder
per verordnung durchgesetzt haben oder
verordnet haben wurden aufgrund einer
ganz allgemein gefassten klausel
verlassen
und das soll mit dem gesetz das heute
verabschiedet werden soll geändert
werden
es sollen konkrete maßnahmen bestimmt
werden die zulässig sind also man muss
sich das ein bisschen vorstellen wie
leitplanken die landesregierung können
jetzt nicht mehr einfach beliebig
maßnahmen ergreifen die sie für richtig
halten sondern der bundestag gibt ganz
konkret vor welche maßnahmen sind
zulässig
und da gibt es einen katalog das sind
die maßnahmen die wir alle fast alle
schon kennen also zb die masten pflicht
abstandsgebot die schließung von
gaststätten die schließung von
geschäften oder die absage von
veranstaltungen und es gibt aber auch
vorgaben wann diese maßnahmen konkret in
kraft treten sollen und dürfen also wir
haben das schon gesehen es gibt diese
zahlen 35 und 50 neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohner in den vergangenen
sieben tagen das ist ein richtwert der
im gesetz steht und es gibt auch für
besonders eingriffs intensiv für
grundrechte wie die versammlungsfreiheit
oder gottesdienste oder auch der besuch
in altenpflegeheimen da gibt es noch mal
eine besonders hohe schwelle
da steht im gesetz diese maßnahmen
dürfen erst dann ergriffen werden oder
diese grundrechte erst dann angetastet
werden wenn alle anderen maßnahmen keine
wirkung oder keine wirkung die sozusagen
zur bekämpfung der pandemie ausreichend
zeigt haben also hier hat der
gesetzgeber auch noch eine extra hohe
hürde eingezogen
und die reicht oder wird es am ende dann
doch vielleicht vom verfassungsgericht
landen
also es ist davon auszugehen dass dieses
gesetz in jedem fall vor dem
verfassungsgericht vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht in karlsruhe
landen wird davon ist schwer auszugehen
und vorherzusagen wie dieses urteil dann
aussieht
das ist sehr schwer also es gibt
verschiedenste kritik daran und eine ein
kritikpunkt ist dass diese maßnahmen
dort nur aufgezählt werden es aber keine
anleitung oder keine hinweise an die
landesregierungen gibt wie die
verhältnismäßigkeit konkret geprüft
werden soll
also wir haben ja in diesen fällen immer
zwei grundrechte oder mehrere
grundrechte die gegeneinander abgewogen
werden
wir haben auf der einen seite die
gesundheit von uns allen aber auch die
vermeidung einer überlastung des
gesundheitssystems also das trifft ja
jetzt immer mehr in den vordergrund
diese zweite aspekt und auf der anderen
seite haben wir aber die ganzen
grundrechte die uns auch zustehen zum
beispiel die versammlungsfreiheit oder
die berufsausübungsfreiheit also darf
ich mein restaurant betreiben und diese
beiden grundrechte liegen dann in einer
waagschale und dann muss man juristisch
sehen was wiegt schwerer
und welche wer also welches grundrecht
ist ihr wissen in welchem grund richtet
ist der vorzug zu geben und das eine
sehr schwierige entscheidung und da gibt
es unter juristinnen und juristen
durchaus kritik dass das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz hier zu unkonkret
bleibt und was die verhältnismäßigkeit
angeht zu wenige hinweise an die
landesregierung gibt einfach mal bei
einem verfassungsgericht denn der
frühere präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts papier hat von
einem persilschein für die
bundesregierung gesprochen
ich denke dass er damit auf die
beteiligungsrechte des parlamentes
eingeht wie sieht es mit diesen
beteiligungsrechten aus nach der
jetzigen gesetzesfassung wie sie
verabschiedet werden sollen reicht das
unterricht ist also zum einen muss man
sagen dass jetzt das parlament zum
ersten mal wirklich grundsätzliche
entscheidung getroffen hat oder treffen
wird also die debatte läuft noch aber
mal angenommen das parlament stimmte zu
dann ist das in jedem fall eine
beteiligung des parlaments die in den
vergangenen acht monaten nicht
stattgefunden hat insofern ist es aus
demokratischer sicht durchaus ein großer
fortschritt und von einem
ermächtigungsgesetz oder n
oder einem abbau von demokratie kann an
dieser stelle gar keine rede sein das
ist das gegenteil der fall
das parlament als vertreter des volkes
wird jetzt zum ersten mal richtig
beteiligt es gibt aber zwei aspekte die
man unter dem aspekt unter dem stichwort
beteiligung der parlamente durchaus auch
kritisch sehen kann der eine aspekt ist
das der bundestag nach dem gesetzentwurf
nur informiert werden soll und
informieren das was anderes als mitreden
oder mit entscheiden
das heißt der bsw ist ja auch die
möglichkeit gegeben dass der bundestag
in bestimmten zeitabständen die
entscheidungen oder die maßnahmen
überprüft und nochmal anpasst und so
weiter so was ähnliches hätte die spd
gerne gehabt die cdu hat das aber
blockiert der andere aspekt ist dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht seit
jahrzehnten einen grundsatz aufgestellt
hat das alle wesentlichen entscheidungen
in der demokratie vom parlament zu
treffen sind
und hier ist jetzt die frage reicht es
aus dass das gesetz was heute
verabschiedet wird einfach nur
beispielhaft diese maßnahmen auf zählt
und noch einige hinweise
natürlich gibt wann diese maßnahmen zu
treffen sind waren die sozusagen legitim
sind aber ob das am ende dem
bestimmtheitsgebot satz genügt dass in
diesem gesetz ganz klar festgeschrieben
ist in welchem zeitpunkt ist welche
maßnahme die richtige das ist die frage
und das ist eigentlich eine entscheidung
die dem parlament vorbehalten bleiben
musste oder muss nach dem grundsatz des
bundesverfassungsgerichts und ob das am
ende so ist das müssen die
verwaltungsgerichte und am ende für an
das bundesverfassungsgericht entscheiden
was werden wir bürger denn eigentlich
von diesen infektionsschutzgesetz wenn
es denn verabschiedet ist ganz konkret
merken in unserem alltag werden wir
davon eigentlich eigentlich gar nichts
merken weil die maßnahmen die in diesem
morgen gesetz stehen zur bekämpfung von
krone sind genau die die wir schon
kennen
und das ist auch davon auszugehen dass
diese maßnahmen in einem ähnlichen
umfang oder nach einem ähnlichen maßstab
eingesetzt werden wie es bisher der fall
war
andererseits ist es so dass wir dadurch
dass das parlament der bundestag das
jetzt verabschiedet hat haben wir
natürlich alle einen demokratischen zu
gewinnen weil zum ersten mal das
parlament gesagt hat hier sind die
leitplanken das sind die maßnahmen die
sozusagen
lässig sind das heißt konkret merken wir
nichts aber aus demokratie theoretischer
sicht ist das auf jeden fall ein großer
fortschritt dieses gesetz christian dick
als dankeschön für deine einschätzung
wir werden uns heute abend nochmal sehen
denn liebe user dieser tag bleibt
spannend der bundestag wird noch
entscheiden der bundesrat wird noch
entscheiden der bundespräsident soll
heute abend noch seine unterschrift
unter das gesetz setzen
außerdem gehen natürlich die
demonstration in berlin weiter die
demonstration konnte noch nicht
aufgelöst werden von der polizei die mit
einem sehr schwierigen tag heute rechnet
in der hauptstadt deshalb wollen wir am
ende dieses tages nochmal auf der
ereignisse schauen ganz aktuell bei zdf
heute live um 19.30 und ich hoffe ihr
seid eine dabei bis dahin